before i started working at aws i
honestly didn't really know what the
cloud was
i remember during the days leading up to
my aws interviews i was frantically
trying to watch youtube videos and read
articles just to make sure i could
understand the basic definition of cloud
computing and how aws fits into the
picture thankfully the role i applied
for was an internship in a non-technical
team so the emphasis wasn't on how much
i knew about the cloud and all the
technical concepts that came along with
it i had a lot of fun during that
internship i met tons of cool people and
i worked on some interesting projects
and since then i've converted my
internship into a full-time graduate
role as an associate solutions architect
and i've been in this role for just over
a year now in this time i've gotten five
aws certifications and i also started
this youtube channel to share what it's
like working at aws as an associate
solutions architect i spend a lot of
time these days engaging with customers
and helping them on their cloud journey
by providing technical guidance so
knowing what i know now how would i
learn aws if i were to start over i
joined aws not really knowing much about
cloud computing and i really had to put
in a lot of time and effort into my
learning i've definitely made a few
mistakes throughout my learning process
and so in this video i wanted to share a
three-step roadmap that you can use to
gain a solid understanding of aws and
make sure you watch until the end of
this video because i'll be sharing some
tips and tricks to make sure you don't
burn out or give up throughout this
whole journey all the resources i
mentioned will be linked in the
description below and if you find this
video helpful in any way please make
sure to give it a like all right so
before you dive straight into studying
for aws certifications i would recommend
first getting a basic understanding of
what cloud computing is and also fill in
any initial gaps you may have in your
knowledge you can start off by watching
this three minute video on the aws
official youtube channel that defines
what cloud computing is if there's
anything that sounds unfamiliar to you
for example you're not too sure what a
physical data center is or what
networking is you can fill in these gaps
by doing your research online if you're
already familiar with what cloud
computing is feel free to head straight
to step two step number two is where the
hard work actually begins because
instead of reading blogs and also
watching videos just to get a basic
understanding of the cloud this step is
all about working towards getting an
awful certification the first one i
recommend taking is the aws cloud
practitioner certification getting this
certification shows employers you have a
foundational understanding of aws it
also provides a structured learning
pathway for you because there are
specific topics they will test you on if
you're interested in getting this
certification i recommend checking out
this video i made about how i was able
to pass the aws cloud practitioner exam
in three weeks which was actually my
first ever youtube video the exam is one
and a half hours long and to prepare for
it i followed video courses and did
practice exams i'll link all the
resources i used to study for adb
certifications in the description below
so make sure you take a look if you're
interested now if i were to go back and
redo this step i would also use this
free 6 hour cloud practitioner
essentials course offered by aws i've
heard really great things about this
course so if you don't want to use any
paid resources this could be a really
good one to start with once you get your
aws cloud practitioners set instead of
moving straight to step 3 what i
recommend is also getting your aws
solutions arctic associate cert this one
requires a deeper knowledge of aws and
focuses more on architectural patterns
as well as how to identify the best aws
services for a given technical
requirement now step three is the part
where a lot of people tend to stumble on
and tend to try and avoid and i was
guilty of that as well for a while so at
the end of the day the aws solutions
architect associate exam and other
certification exams they're all multiple
choice exams and to really build your
skills in aws you have to be hands-on
this means doing a lot of aws self-paced
labs having a look at the online
workshops available and trying to build
something that you're able to showcase
there's actually heaps of resources out
there to help with this so the first
resource i recommend is workshops.aws
this is an aws site where you can find
self-paced workshops ranging from all
levels of difficulty so you can see
there's level 300 level 200 level 100 as
well and there's a lot of workshops you
can choose from so for example this aws
networking workshop you can see that it
covers the full spectrum of aws
networking all the way from the basics
of a vpc and subnets to the more
advanced configurations the next
resource is aws ramp up guides and i've
actually recommended this to my
customers before especially customers
who are quite new to the cloud so you
can see that you can choose ramp up
guides by role by solution or by
industry and for example just clicking
on one of the ramp up guides you can see
that they've actually centralized a lot
of the useful materials for example
white papers and self-paced labs the
third resource i'd like to recommend is
actually udemy courses there's actually
a few udemy courses that actually offer
a lot of hands-on experience for example
this one is all about building a
serverless web app with aws lambda and
you can see there's seven and a half
hours of on-demand video so if you
prefer learning through video demos and
having someone walk through the steps
one by one it might be more engaging for
you and easier to follow along okay now
let's talk about some tips and tricks to
make sure you don't give up halfway
through your learning i've written some
notes here and there's a few key things
i wanted to mention the first one is
that you don't have to follow a super
linear approach when you know
approaching your cloud journey when it
comes to aws certifications there's
nothing forcing you to sit through a
whole 50-hour video course before you
start doing practice questions and
before you start trying out some of the
abyss workshops in fact it's actually
better if you don't do that don't go
through the whole video course end to
end and then do the practice exams it's
much better if you focus on the
different topics that the aws
certification covers and then validate
that knowledge through practice
questions and then following that up
with hands-on exercises where you're
able to see what it actually looks like
in the aims console and how these
services work and linked together my
second tip is to always remember your
why so why didn't you decide to embark
on this challenging journey in the first
place i think for a lot of you it might
be to land a job in tech more
specifically in cloud computing and so
getting an aws certification learning
the foundations of aws can really help
you stand out in the application process
if you set that as your end goal you can
work backwards from that and set small
achievable milestones that you have to
complete at the end of each month so for
example in by the end of the first month
you can be like i want to get my aws
certified cloud practitioner exam done
and by setting milestones and
celebrating after every milestone it
would really help you stay motivated and
consistent throughout the whole journey
my third tip is to just be kind to
yourself because everyone learns things
differently and at a different pace as
well and everyone comes from different
technical backgrounds some people might
not know anything about it whereas some
people might be working in tech for a
couple years but don't really understand
cloud concepts yet so i would recommend
never comparing your progress with other
people and just focus on what you want
to achieve all right so this brings us
to the very end of this video hope you
enjoyed it if you did please give it a
like and if you have any questions
comments suggestions leave it down in
the comments below and in the meantime
before i upload my next video feel free
to check out any of these videos to
learn more about what it's like working
at aws